a very popular modder who was working on
a mod for Starfield that would make the
game multiplayer has given up they are
most well known for doing this for
Skyrim for creating a multiplayer mod
for Skyrim and I guess partway through
the Starfield version of this same mod
gave up and uploaded everything they've
done so far so that someone else could
work on it saying this game is
trash quote I'm not going to put my
heart and soul into a mod for a game as
mediocre as this this all came out in
the project dedicated Discord server and
they did already spend a lot of time
apparently porting over gameplay hooks
from Skyrim to get a co-op mod together
for Starfield this is all from games who
also noted that they ported about 70% of
Skyrim together but I guess after that
first initial launch day and Beyond push
they decided they did not like the game
enough to continue